ciao a tutti ben tornati a nick torres
oggi il nuovo video di indovinelli per
vedere se siano dei geni ma l'avete
richiesto perché ho fatto un altro video
di indovinelli mi avete detto che vi
siete divertiti un sacco soprattutto ad
indovinare assieme quindi nuovo pgt
indovinelli noi ora visti sembrano super
interessanti siete pronti concentriamoci
vediamo quanti punti riusciamo a fare
come sempre
dovete tenere a mente i punti che avete
fatto e ottiene video
dovete scrivere quanti punti avete fatto
vedere se ho fatto più punti io o se
avete fatto più punti voi quindi se
avete vinto voi ha subito io è perché
indovini e vi dovete scrivere le vostre
risposte nei commenti prima che io
bella la risposta insomma siete pronti
mettetevi comodi trattative con
ornamenti ok sono tutti indovinelli
molto rapidi
allora indovinello numero uno c'è
scritto quale la porta più sicura
[Applauso]
ok c'è scritto qual è la porta assicura
quella nella prima c'è un assassino
nella seconda c'è un leone che non
mangia da tre anni e nella terza c'è un
incendio ok ragazzi il numero 1 questo
penso che sia molto semplice pensateci
bene
penso che nel resto tutti a questa ma
non lo so mi viene in mente solo questo
comunque nella prima azione assassino
analizziamo bene rapporto nella prima
c'è un assassino quindi non è figur
nella seconda c'è un leone che non
mangia da tre anni
e nella terza un incendio
come fai le donne che non mangia da tre
anni essere ancora vivo quindi penso che
nella seconda ci sia un leone morto
quindi io dico la seconda porta scrivete
voi nei commenti secondo voi qual è la
porta più sicura e vediamo la risposta
[Musica]
forse la prima forza perché no aperta ma
prendo tutte ok si chiude one
iscritto non ha mangiato domanda da tre
anni quindi è morto quindi a fine seduta
rapporto con quello 2 e incredibile ha
fatto un condominio o allora dice quale
si riempirà prima di queste quattro
cisterne vediamo se qualche animazione
[Musica]
abbiamo solo 5 secondi ok quale si
ritira prima allora la prima nella prima
l'acqua passa 4 poi passare per arrivare
qua si dovrebbe riempire di più per
spingerla fino al 4
io dico il numero 3 ma la sony punto
dico il numero 3 scrivete voi nei
commenti qualche riempirà prima di
queste quattro cisterne vediamo
sia a 3 che a 4 quindi se voi avete
scritto 3 contro avete scritto quattro
avete fatto un punto
incredibile un'altra appunto questa
volta mi sta andando bene questa volta
mi hanno trattato bene
penso che mi avete battuto voi comunque
sono due punti passiamo al prossimo che
questo e di odio queste allora illumina
di un volto il quale si ritira prima tra
queste tasse di crescenti allora
mettiamo un po ma fa parte l'emozione
allora non capisco una cosa perché sono
chiusi qua quindi vuol dire che questi
non vanno a riempirsi qua è chiuso
quindi non si riesce ed immagino poi
aperto qualche se poi aperto quindi
dobbiamo capire se si riempì la prima la
numero 4 con la numero due è più basso
rispetto a questo quindi riempendosi
andrebbe prima qua ma poi chiuse così di
numeri anche qua quindi qua si riempie
ma non va da nessuna parte quindi cade
per forza 4 e si riempe equa e mappa ok
io dico la numero due mentre voi
scrivete la vostra risposta per il
minore numero 3 quale tazza di caffe
prima vediamo
non ci posso credere il nome alle
nocciole risposta ha corretto
io odio quando parlo di non dare una
risposta perché devo sapere la risposta
scrivetemi come che se sapete dare
esposta o il vostro ragionamento questo
che non fu più comunque intoppi del
numero 4
mister james è stato trovato molto nella
sostanza la stanza non aveva nessuna
finestra e la porta era chiusa chiusa a
chiave
le uniche quattro persone che avevano la
chiave sono state interrogate
[Musica]
ok sofia la l'inserviente ha detto che è
andato a svegliare mister james e quando
la questo porto ha urlato che sarà un
assassino
john il maggiordomo dice che qui ho
appena sentito urlare e corsa nella
stanza
[Applauso]
[Musica]
acceso la luce e ha visto che mister
centra un coltello sul collo nel collo
appunto sul collo killer è stata
ok sarà la dalla governante dice che è
corsa sul piano di sopra
insieme al john
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando acceso la luce la stanza piena di
sante poi abbiamo l'ultimo sospetto jack
the kooks jack il top
e lui dice io stavo preparando la
colazione e non ho visto niente
una pretendente chi è stato ok abbiamo
solo queste informazioni per scoprire
che stabilisse ossia entrate all'altro
fatto molto e urlato journal adesso col
coltello nel collo sta adesso tutto pena
del tar e il jack non ho visto niente
perché faceva colazione
allora io non lo so mi butto dico che è
stato jack perché siccome faceva
colazione aveva il coltello in mano
probabilmente perché stava preparando la
colazione del coltello è andata la
ucciso col coltello il di quell'ex
scrivete voi la vostra risposta nei
commenti
affidiamo subito chiesto estate sofia
perché sapete perchè fate sofia perché
sofia che era la chi erano sapiente
hanno detto che era entrata nella stanza
a stanza era buio e lo ha visto morto
serata sofia perché se la stanza era
buia lì non poteva vedere che era morto
quindi vuol dire che lo sapeva di già
perché l'avevo indovinello numero 56
chiuso in una stanza quale porta scegli
siamo non può aumentare le porte la
salvezza e dietro una di queste tre
porte in una sentire al killer che ha
ucciso 300 persone il 1890
[Applauso]
[Musica]
nella seconda ci sono 1800 30 gradi e
fiamme
[Applauso]
[Musica]
m la prima centro gen un liquido che ti
congela
[Applauso]
quando scegliamo la 123 per evitare di
essere tarati bruciati o uccisi
allora questa penso che sia la
sistematica di quella del leone è
secondo me la porta in cui sappiamo la
numero 3 perché c'è scritto che essere
accoglierà ucciso 300 persone nel 1860
quindi è morto e sepolto ormai quindi
scelgono il numero 30 che penso più
ormai serial killer non ci sia più c'è
list in cui la vostra risposta nei
commenti
vediamo i ragazzi era questa la risposta
al titolo profonda nel 1890 e molto
tanto tempo fa quindi se anche voi avete
letto la porta numero 3 avete fatto un
altro punto io ovviamente ho perso il
conto come sempre mi sembra questo
quattro punte io mi ricordo che
indovinello numero 6
una mattina piccola mary e massa
intrappolata in un castello in costa
rica piccola mary cosa ci facevi dentro
un cappello incolta inc sempre queste
forte comunque ci siano quattro porte è
solo una porta alla libertà
vediamo cosa certo che se porta il fuoco
sia sempre più gioco anche qua un drago
eccola là nel tempo macellava nella
prima c'è la lava che ti toglie
immediatamente
nella seconda c'è il clown assassino che
picchierebbe una persona fino alla morte
che picchierebbe ogni persona fino alla
morte aiuto non è la numero 3 la numero
cresce del ghiaccio che la congelerebbe
all'istante
[Musica]
nel numero 4 c'è ci sono dei poliziotti
che sparerebbero ogni uomo o donna
indiscriminatamente
non capisco perché dovrebbe vedersi
deboli impianti che sbagliano uomini e
donne continua a caso vabbè comunque è
con voi qual è la distanza che porta
alla salvezza
allora secondo me la numero 4 non sono
sicura però dicono al numero 4
semplicemente perché hanno scritto che
questi poliziotti sparerebbero ogni uomo
o donna indiscriminatamente ma non hanno
detto bambini perché alla luce c'era
scritto che si chiama piccola veri ed
era piccolina quindi matrix e una
bambina
quindi io dico la vengono 4 però potrei
sbagliarmi quindi voi scrivete la vostra
risposta nei commenti
1234 e scrivete anche per te dovrò di
vedere i vostri ragionamenti nei
commenti vediamo la risposta non si
possa credere dobbiate un più questa
ovviamente non sto parlando
questo perché ogni tanto qualcuno ogni
volta che riesco a fare qualche punto
piccolo sta imparando allora dovrete
vedere gli altri vinicole più spazio di
punti comunque era abbastanza semplice
eh si la risposta è che loro c'era
scritto appunto che avrebbero sparato
qualsiasi uomo o donna ma neri non è una
lui indovinello numero 6 mi sembra la
polizia è stata chiamata da alice la
governante linz dopo che ha trovato il
corpo di mister james mangiano tutti lo
stesso nome stesso momento
9 comunque se ha trovato il corpo di
metterci dice che lei stava pulendo
quando ha sentito il suono di uno sparo
ha chiamato mister janis e ha lasciato
un messaggio ma perché non farà una casa
a lui non stava a casa
comunque lei ha fatto un messaggio
dicendoli che qualcosa di brutto è
successo qualcosa era successo qualcosa
di brutto e che doveva arrivare a casa
immediatamente la polizia è riuscita a
fuori dalla casa e ha trovato mister
james che si stava avvicinando alla casa
allora ho fatto un errore di traduzione
a litio sull'ospite un mister james
maranta era mrf james che vuol dire
misses j
quindi la moglie di james è stata
trovata morta non genetica trucks sa più
che cosa ci fa il vivo che cammina
comunque davis che stata trovata morta e
appunto lizza ambiente ha sentito queste
spalle e subito chiamato biglietti
ritornare la polizia si è avvicinata a
lui e lui ha detto me terribile chi ho
mai potuto sparare o mia moglie
la polizia lo ha arrestato
immediatamente
così perché quando voi perché no perché
stato immediatamente la polizia come mi
viene solo da pensare che lui abbia
detto qualcosa che loro non avevano
ancora svelato subito creano però dello
sparo che l'aveva già detto
l'inserviente chiamandolo realta detto
che ha sentito uno sparo quindi lui lo
sapeva già
non possono averlo incastrato in questo
modo sommi punte dico non lo so che
aveva aveva qualche non so macchia di
sangue rosso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la risposta e addio è veramente stupido
la risposta è che nessuno aveva detto
mister james che era stata la moglie ad
essere sparata massei maroni che in casa
ci dovrà essere indovinare il numero
sette quadri ed omicidi niente lava
mente fuoco che ti uccide niente serial
killer per fortuna ci sono due isole e
sono connette da un ponticello in
un'isola c'è un ragazzo con un albero di
mele e dell'altro c'è una ragazza c'è
scritto che il ponte correggere il
ragazzo è una mela allo stesso tempo
quindi ripeto del ragazzo ma lui deve
portare due me e alla ragazza
il ragazzo può attraversare il ponte
solo una volta cosa deve fare per
portarli due mele allora innanzitutto
perché dove per forza mangiarne 2 invece
di una non lo capone altra cosa che non
ho capito è perchè se le isole sono così
vicini non gliele lancio di rete
l altro che due deve puntare 56 ma
facciamo finta che sono più lontane se
lui può passare solo una volta con una
mela perché non possa lei prendere due
mele e poi torna anche perché ne può
passare più di una volta penso se non
hanno specificato dove la mia risposta e
non so se giusta che passa lei se le
prende e torna anche perché lei forse
più leggera di lui
non penso che non pare fonte questi suoi
dalla risposta dei commenti e vediamo
[Musica]
non so bene
preferivo se ci fosse stato scritto
basta che gliene lancia nell'altra isola
detto più vicina a tre è stata ben
contenta c'è scritto che lui deve
attraversare il ponte come fece jogging
in italiano comunque tirandola mele come
come i giocolieri no le due mele così in
questo modo una meno estera sempre in
aria e terribile le risposte di questi
nomi ne vorrei vedere altri perché mi
diverto troppo però non voglio che
questo video sia troppo lungo quindi
fatemi sapere nei commenti se volete che
facciamo altri domini assieme come
sempre però io
una risposta io quindi non so più un bel
live se volete vederne altre diecimila
likes andrò a farne altri e ora vi
lascio fa costa castellini su cui potete
cliccare se volete vedere altre mie
challenge altro medium inaridito che i
verdetti cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione